in August the world will come together
in the Brazilian city of Rio de Janeiro
for the 31st Olympic Games
[Music]
the global competition will be gripping
but which country will top the medal
table one nation battling for supremacy
will be the People's Republic of China
Western media is rarely granted access
to China's secretive Olympic training
camps
[Music]
Gilligan you - Leela you once I - are
you gonna go either we go or Canada
Chingiz a melodic load our partnership
has real talent you got a block under
Nikita melancholy she could be some
other girl
Eagle Eagle some of the legislature so
the woman cheated Samuel as well
Kaneesha she lunches Anja Kaneesha since
to achieve all of it
[Music]
the Chinese have a plan for knocking
America off the top of the medal table
in Rio a ruthless focus on events that
play to their strengths and they're not
in track and field
whadda somewhere and without time y'all
tackle - latisha from young man Tara
would you to make we ran out to the Sun
tea de niro
Thiago Buchanon Arrowhead and neon green
color zero talking huh
free woman and getting some of our
children room SEMA Dan Halen's hot yoga
would you the hydrogen charging
only two men will be chosen to represent
China at trampoline in Rio
23 year old gal a is tipped to be one of
them oh she's very shiny on you is shows
total scan zillions huh we were by offer
Juliana his coach has already produced
two gold medal winners in this event you
know gran single atomic harshly Jenna
tell you the would see where I couldn't
help - Aisha picked at a young age gal a
is a product of the world's largest mass
recruitment and sports training program
51,000 athletes are currently training
at elite national and regional
Institute's like this one and a further
four hundred thousand children are
housed in local Olympic schools across
the country
Hangzhou is 800 miles south of Beijing
children at this training school are
recruited from six years old
[Music]
Jin when she has been in intensive
training for three years but she's still
only nine and yet to dream of the
Olympics the Godsey might jump jump a
the wedding and I will L go lucky bow so
you have the beauty Daniel Day will be
like you know recruiters like Chen Chen
visit hundreds of towns and villages in
their regions testing thousands of small
children against a host of specific
physiological criteria then I'll also
need an onion Tyler honey this Cynthia
foods a male and they don't try you then
it only the hot run you shouted
searching roses on tuna it's just over
it's a scientific approach from height
and weight to muscle mass and posture
Jin when she displays early signs of an
Olympic champion would you what pigeon
the new year in Chara hotel kind of
hello table hand Holly I went ding no
need come on and oh I agree
she has the physical attributes for
trampoline but children are tested for
many different events
hang on ha yo music oh this is a finally
her [ __ ] yes only not surgery you
could be the chairman the Chairman
ASEAN's head of yoga chances ching ching
hai the house Nami Yahoo Tessa's had a
switch on Hong Kong
in 2013 alone China pumped more than 1
billion dollars into the national
Olympic training infrastructure
significantly more than any other
government critics say intensive
training programs like these are
tantamount to child abuse but the
coaches here argue these children are
getting far better education and
opportunities than others some in the
formal team but Amazon now was all
realized really well to have a loser she
was held on $3 so what city gates leader
Ali our producer dynamic what touches on
ing to the launch it
y'all tire you pursue number on you all
right
what's on top of her Inga has the
quickest and I shall show how China's
hot the chances of these children making
it to the Olympics are statistically
very small but if they can avoid injury
and make the national team the reward
can be life-changing gold medal winners
are usually offered a high-ranking
government job and will receive around
200-thousand dollars in prize money was
indicted among unusual 12800 are upon
you you don't download your breathing or
ECG where she'll washing lightly no God
and no matching know what candidate you
pinja have an Oregon you but Olympic
medals don't come cheap
what you don't realize is when Syria
Tony and they're quite low you a woman
are you Carrie Lynch dorama
eyes here senators working and my
mineral so wounded and no the doctor via
heart sister - for shawarma G don't you
wait a joke King King no heart at Waimea
- an inferno
you